realmente tiene algún impacto esta clase
de sanciones
bueno La idea es seguir mostrando el
compromiso de sostener a Ucrania
sí pueden llegar o sea hay versiones de
que este Rusia está sufriendo y hay
otras versiones de que no está sufriendo
tanto por el el el apoyo masivo que
también que recibe de China entonces
este es algo en el medio las sanciones
no han tenido el efecto esperado en el
en este en este plazo de este de moderar
o de frenar a la posición de Putin sin
embargo se sabe que las sanciones en el
largo tiempo pueden afectar a quien las
recibe pero al mismo tiempo también las
sanciones afectan a quienes las emiten
porque se pierde comercio porque hay que
reemplazarlo usted hablaba a Gran
Bretaña que suspende la importación de
ciertos metales va a tener que
obtenerlos de por otro camino lo que
pasa es que este Europa en este caso a
este a este tiempo que estamos pasando
ya que se inició la Guerra más de un año
en Europa el apoyo de los g7 es que los
países
del digamos la mayoría de los países del
Mundo del importante no están dispuestos
a tolerar modificaciones o cambios en la
geografía en el estatus quo en el
trazado en el diseño que se ha
establecido Sí el g7 todavía no prohíbe
totalmente en bloque el comercio con
diamantes rusos sino que lo hace de
manera parcial por qué enfocarse en los
diamantes concretamente
bueno porque los diamantes se van a se
ha descubierto que es una se hacían
descubiertos de hecho notorio que Rusia
vendió diamante por cinco mil millones
de dólares Entonces ese es un número
importante que puede afectar a la a la
economía Entonces es un área que uno
pensaría que no es estratégica en una
socialidad de amantes Con lujo pero los
diamantes también sirven para para la
ciertas herramientas que tienen que con
este con perforación tiene que ver
también con cierta producción de
armamento seguramente lo interesante de
estas sanciones es que no es solo ya
sobre Rusia sino que va a empezar a
mirar terceros países que triangulen el
comercio con Rusia eso es un esto
también se adapta O sea si le agregan
nuevas medidas porque las que están
hasta ahora no brindan el efecto
esperado en el corto plazo listo y le
quería preguntar También usted Nos
estaba hablando de terceros países de
hecho el g7 en su comunicado propuso
crear una base de datos donde se pueda
identificar el origen de los granos y
acusan a Rusia de quedarse con granos
ucranianos Qué tan efectiva podría ser
esa base de datos
puede ser efectiva en la medida que
tenga los los datos reales de vuelta
todo esto sirve para complicar aquello
que tratan de hacer maniobras ilegales
llevarlas adelante el problema la clave
de todos estos temas es que usted puede
crear todas las comisiones y todos los
controles que quieran pero si los
actores que tienen que deben hacerlas
cumplir no están tan comprometidos estos
también se se dificulta y puede ser que
cada tanto aparezca algún este algún
agujerito en el en el en el en este en
el procedimiento No pero de vuelta esto
Mostrar la voluntad de este de ajustar
lo más posible para o sea las sanciones
tienen un modo de que buscan terminar el
conflicto
del menor modo al menor costo